yeah now that uh obviously Kentucky's
obviously a thing now but when you came
out it was not a thing it was not yeah
well we had people from you know had
Nappy Roots Nappy Roots player static
major ah yeah you know
um but I just mean in terms of like
being on the Forefront like you were
like like on a Star level it was just
you yeah now you got estg you got Jack
Harlow we do you and Jack have been
locked in for a long time
um what is it like now just to see like
the home state really kind of
you know have some real representation
um when for a while you were kind of
standing on the mountain by yourself
man I was just saying this earlier this
like it's a relief you know it was a
person felt like it was all eyes on me
you know now I knew that sometimes I
knew at some point that like somebody
would come up out of the city like it's
crazy I low-key predicted um estg Jack
came out of nowhere but um you know I
was like man it's only a matter of time
before we get like a street artist you
know you know somebody who's like
rapping to the streets from Louisville
um and then next thing you know the STG
comes out and I was just like yeah no
it's a guy yeah so uh